[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le 12 avril 1961 un coup de tonnerre
résonne à travers le monde la russie
soviétique réussi à projeter un homme
dans l'espace à le placer en valeurs
vitales autour de la terre et à le
ramener vivant
à vrai dire depuis le 4 octobre 1957
date de lancement du premier spoutnik le
grand public s'attendait à semblable
prouesse mais on ne pensait pas qu'elle
aurait lieu aussi tôt
en effet depuis ce jour le chemin
parcouru est immense il est difficile d
tenez là la première surprise passée il
s'est habitué doucement au spoutnik et
aux explorer
on a bien suivi par radio les évolutions
de la chaîne nhk mais enfin et ce qui
n'existerait jamais un homme satellite
et bien ça y est cet homme c'est youri
alexeïevitch gagarine
il a été lancé à bord d'un engin dont le
poids atteignait le chiffre formidable
de 4725 il
une fusée à trois étages réussissait à
le lancer dans le ciel à l'altitude de
280 km et à le placer sur une orbite
prévue est choisi
[Musique]
l'altitude la vitesse et l'état
d'apesanteur ne l'ont en rien un commode
et ceci grâce à la préparation intensive
subi avant l'envol il avait dû vaincre
la peur de la solitude oublier que lors
du décollage son sens serait aussi lourd
que lui mercure et qu'ils risqueraient
d'être volatilisé lors de sa rentrée
dans l'atmosphère
comme on l'avait fait au sol on a pu
contrôler tout instant le jeu de sa
respiration sa tension artérielle et son
état nerveux il a pu boire manger se
servir de ses mains et même écrire sur
son carnet son attention ne s'est jamais
relâché son esprit est resté lucide et
son coeur n'a pas cessé de battre
régulièrement malgré l'état la pesanteur
entraîné à 28 milles kilomètres heure
gagarine a retrouvé la terre après 108
minutes de vol ayant fait un tour
complet de notre planète
le premier cosmonaute est revenu le
sourire aux lèvres prêt de recommencer à
moscou et dans la russie entière éclater
le sens du trio il ne parlera de
monstres a lieu sur la place rouge
tandis que la foule s'abandonne à une
joie délirante youri gagarine est devenu
un héros national
[Musique]
e
aujourd'hui l'exploit du 12 avril 1961
semble bien dépasse le manège des hommes
autour de la terre se poursuit et il est
proche peut être très proche le temps où
l'homme pourra accomplir le fabuleux
voyage qui le conduira plus près des
planètes soeurs de sa terre natale
[Musique]